Heads up, major Deadpool 2 spoilers ahead.
The highly-anticipated Deadpool sequel was
chock-full of surprising cameos: Matt Damon
was tucked in as a redneck with a wealth of
bathroom-related knowledge, Brad Pitt had
a blink-and-you-miss-it appearance as the
invisible hero Vanisher, and even Ryan Reynolds
took on an additional role, popping up as
the voice of Juggernaut.
But by the looks of it, there may have been
was another character cameo hidden in the
sequel, none other than the Joker himself.
"You sure you're not from the DC universe?"
When Deadpool and Russell are shipped off
to the criminal-packed prison called the Icebox,
the pair meet a hodgepodge of dangerous bad
guys and random freaks.
But if fans look closely in the crowd, they'll
spot a man who looks uncannily like Jared
Leto's Joker.
He's got the white skin and bright green hair,
and no close Marvel character comparisons.
It's hard to argue that he isn't DC's Clown
Prince of Crime.
There are two extra bits of evidence throughout
the film that bolster the argument that Joker
made an appearance.
The first is a gun that's shown with a "bang!"
flag popping out of its barrel, which looks
kinda similar to the flag that's flung out
of the Joker's gun in Tim Burton's 1989 Batman
movie.
The second comes during the sequence in which
Cable asks Deadpool to identify himself, Deadpool
cheekily responds, "I'm Batman," using a voice
that sounds like former Batman actor Michael
Keaton's.
At the end of the day, either the team behind
the Deadpool sequel included the iconic villain
but won't admit to it because Warner Brothers
holds the rights to the character, or this
is all just one big coincidence.
Fans can decide for themselves when they catch
Deadpool 2 in a repeat viewing.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!